hey all this is Justin hey Walt reading
dan Starkey's review of Hyrule warriors
definitive edition for Nintendo switch
Hyrule warriors is a beautiful chaotic
mess of a game it's got all the glossy
rupees imaginative monsters and
fashionable characters you'd expect from
the Zelda series and plenty of wooden
topped off with some nods to the
medieval hack-and-slash dynasty warrior
series in place of puzzles and elaborate
levels or side quests you're here to do
one thing mess up some monsters this
shouldn't be new to most folks as the
original run of Hyrule warriors launched
back in 2014 but the ports a Nintendo
switch brings all the extra characters
and items from the DLC plus some added
costumes and all the content from the
3ds version that's a ton of content to
bring to the table but the games central
theme is the same as ever that makes
this switch version a tough sell for all
but the most dedicated fans of the
original or those who never set foot
into the wacky world of this strange
mashup given the Wii U's relatively
meager sales though this is a great
second chance for the strongest Zelda
spin-off ever
for the unfamiliar dynasty warriors is a
tactical action game that tasks you with
managing an army and controlling
specific keeps or tracks of land all the
while you're able to insert yourself
directly into the fray as an uber
powered demigod that allows you to shift
the tide of battle essentially acting as
the Queen in chess powerful though you
may be you've also got to keep constant
track of the field and where you're
needed most that tension between the
battle right in front of you and the
tactical considerations of the field
represent the core tension of the series
Hyrule warriors doesn't compromise on
that at all and even mixes in plenty of
mid game quests and objectives to keep
you juggling your goals and constantly
weighing your best options it's a lot to
have going on at once but it genuinely
works choices are always build as risks
should you go home and shore up the
defenses of your base or press on for a
valuable collectable understanding where
you're needed most and how the various
elements of a map all play together is
important but it's not so taxing that
you can't fudge your way through a good
chunk of it and that's part of the
appeal as a link or da Rooney ax or
Zelda or Impa you've got the entire
Hyrule cast at your back
Zelda isn't some Rando she's a monster
busting fiend even when you've got more
important decisions to make
watching Zelda summon Spears and swords
from brawl light and dispatching wave
after wave of mob lands is the kind of
cathartic release that many have been
waiting decades for this is fanservice
and its most pure and most satisfying
seeing the characters you've grown up
with or idolized in new contexts that
allow them to unleash their full might
is a bit like taking your favorite
characters into Smash Brothers or marvel
vs. capcom there's an essence of
childlike fascination that comes along
with it and hyrule warriors wields that
well
[Music]
fans of Zelda lore and the like need not
turn their noses up at this adventure
either provided you can buy into the
initial premise and get some mileage
there The Adventure is truly a
fascinating one you'll cross dimensions
and time lines bouncing between locales
from many of the more recent Zelda
entries including Wind Waker breadth of
the wild and Skyward Sword all of this
fits tonally 2 with more than a dozen
characters from all over the timeline in
Zelda's own history of world swapping
time warping weirdness muddling the
timelines between worlds a bit to get
everyone into the same games feels
natural if anything as we stated in our
original review the one major issue this
brings up is the longing for flash sheer
attacks and better combos in the
mainline Zelda series and when a
spin-off makes you want more from the
original that's certainly a special sort
of accomplishment new to the switch
specifically though a split-screen
multiplayer the original allowed one
player to use the gamepad and another to
play on the TV this mode honestly while
nice isn't much of an improvement this
switch can still chug a bit when the
action gets heavy and trying to pack two
players and the mayhem they caused into
a single screen feels a little tight
still it's always nice to have the
option those returning to the fray will
likely be disappointed as there just
isn't enough to satisfy the full retail
price tag for newcomers though Hyrule
warriors is a delightful bizarre outing
that opens up the Zelda series taking us
places we've been before
just this time with thousands of
monsters and awesome screen clearing
magical blasts
[Music]